author Junot Diaz is an immigrant who
grew up in New Jersey he won the
Pulitzer Prize back in 2008 for his
best-selling book remember this the
brief wondrous life of Oscar Wow it
topped a BBC culture poll of the best
novels of the 21st century
now Diaz is releasing his very first
children's book it's called Island born
the book draws on his experiences as a
young immigrant to the u.s. from the
Dominican Republic
Junot Diaz joins us at the table we are
delighted about that here's a book you
said that makes you happy
those were your words Junot Diaz he said
this book actually makes me happy and I
guess that we can thank your
goddaughters for that they asked you to
do this about 20 years ago yeah I did
take you so long I'm really really slow
I look terrible I have a picture of them
of when they asked me and a picture of
them when they got the book and it's
it's embarrassing yeah what did they say
to you at the time you know they like
most children when they find out that
you're a writer the first thing they say
is write me a book man the last thing
I'm not anything but fast well it's so
interesting in your own life you didn't
have a children's book you didn't read
children's book you said growing up yeah
I mean I came from a community where the
only book that I grew up around in the
Dominican Republic was the Bible and it
was a real adult centric you know as a
kid you look at the pages and you're
just like yeah there's nothing there for
me you know yeah when you're writing at
all or in this book is it that you're
that ideas have to ripen they're in your
head or you're just getting distracted
by other things and was there an idea
here that ripened and then you thought
okay now it's time to write yeah I think
what ends up happening is if a book you
want people to fall in love with it and
love is super rare it's really rare some
of you perhaps not rare but you know the
fall in love with a book requires a lot
of work and if I want someone to fall in
love with my book I gotta fall in love
with it so that takes just a lot of work
well let's talk a little bit about the
book so Lola is the main character and
she is Island born but she can't
remember the island right yeah I think a
lot of us a lot of us can't remember our
origins
one of the things that happens and we're
surrounded by them we hear our parents
talking all the time about places they
grew up around or events that happened
before we could remember we grow up with
grandparents who often bring an entirely
different world
we're shaped by places and people that
we've never ever met and that's
something important to recognize our
origins are a part of our identity so
this is about identity formation about
from places you were from how does that
process take place for a keep for an
older person but also for then a little
kid I think that we tell each other
stories I think all of us when we think
about our grandparents if you have the
fortune to grow up around your
grandparents you through gainer you're
lucky enough you remember how gentle
they are how caring the are but you also
remember their stories it seemed to come
from another planet and stories bind us
across time and across space we have to
point out the illustrations will show
some of them while you're talking but
one of my favorite lines in the book -
Lola she says just because her
grandmother says just because you don't
remember place doesn't mean it's not in
you
you never name the island specifically
and you never and there's a monster of
course which there's always a good
monster in a book because with monsters
come heroes you never name the island
and you never name the monster why I
think it's important to leave space for
people to play and for people to project
their own imaginations and their own
experiences also my goddaughters were
raised both in Puerto Rico and the
Dominican Republic so I want to make
sure that you know I didn't lock playing
favorites yeah I didn't get any more
trouble let me ask you about a teacher
you said was really influential I'm
fascinated by these connections teachers
makes with students you said that the
teacher took you to the library and at
that moment changed your life why
because in some ways we need models to
understand what we could possibly become
until that moment I had no idea that it
was possible to somehow live a life with
books I assumed I could be a ball player
maybe if I was super brilliant I could
be the doctor we saw every now and then
but the idea that you could live a life
with books and this librarian gave that
to me as a gift she showed me a door
that I could possibly walk through and
and because of her I walk
through it and guess what now you're the
teacher you're teaching writing at MIT
hey what do you think it's like for your
students do they know that it's you
who's up there teaching do you think
they know who's teaching them ah most of
them are so busy trying to fill classes
and being like overwhelmed by everything
that's happening that they don't do a
lot you know so you're a Pulitzer Prize
winner I think maybe a few but most of
them walk in and know it's your lesson
to them what's your first lesson when
they walk in the door what's your lesson
yeah probably first you know if you
can't if you don't got any room for this
class don't take it because they're
overwhelmed and second you know the
absolute importance of stories and it
sometimes takes twenty years maybe
another day I don't want to just you
know it's just get on the word processor
okay I'm done my lunch
yeah I don't want to tell them that at
the beginning about anything because
they they want to be billionaires before
the semester is over so I don't want to
discourage you know how much time it
often takes so you say regardless of
what kind of writer you are whether
you're a beginning writer and a claim
writer it all starts for you with the
story and the stories that are not being
told I mean we live in a society that
defines itself not by the stories it
tells by what it doesn't tell and what
you are as a writer is a person who's
telling the stories that we don't tell
we don't want to tell certain kinds of
stories we feel uncomfortable and but if
you really are interested in being an
artist the same way of being a
journalist you find the stories the
people are ignoring so not to focus on
the hard part of writing what about the
hopeful part that getting you through
the occasional moments where you have to
you know work a little harder than maybe
well as I said you you're driven by the
fact that you love this form I mean I
love reading deeply love reading every
time I lose hope or I lose track I just
read a couple books to rekindle the fact
that this is what I do is give people
the opportunity to fall in love fall in
love with a book fall in love with a
story fall in love with a character and
that's not small thing I've experienced
it I know what it can do to you that's
right it's the center of our lives to
nerdiest thank you so much thank you
very much